[Music]
mr wayne
you know you really could be doing more
for this city
your family has a history of
philanthropy but as far as i can tell
you're not doing anything
i'm elected i want to change
that thank you
my god
i'm gonna go pay my respects will you
wait for me i'm gonna continue this
[Music]
excuse me chief can i talk to you
[Music]
guilt coulson is missing what
he hasn't been heard from since last
night
christ not again hey
mr wayne
you got people looking for him jim
there's a couple guys to his house
nothing
but his wife saying she hadn't heard
from him
[Music]
back down
get out of the car and show your hands
get out
get them up
get out show up
christ it's coulson
[Music]
clear this place out now
the batman greedy pg-13 experienced it
in imax only theaters march 4th
sorry i wouldn't be bothering you here
but your people keep telling me you're
unavailable
you know you really could be doing more
for this city
your family has a history of
philanthropy but as far as i can tell
you're not doing anything
the riddler
is asking for you the killer left this
for the batman why is he writing to you
it's all about the wings
if we don't stand up no one will
you got a lot of cats i have a thing
about strength
the bat and the cat
it's got a nice ring new friend of yours
i'm not so sure
i'm just here to unmask the truth about
this cesspool we call a city
you're part of this too
how am i part of this
oh you're really not as smart as i
thought
[Music]
we all have our scars bruce you're still
away
he's involved in this oh he's not
involved how do you know
why are you under there
what are you hiding selena don't throw
your life away
don't worry honey i got nine of them
it can be cruel poetic or blind
but when it's denied it's your violence
you may find
justice the answer is justice
come on vengeance
let's get into some trouble
[Music]
you